big news hit just a few moments ago
student loan forgiveness is not
happening it is official now the Supreme
Court officially struck down Biden
student loan debt relief plan that would
have forgiven up to 20 grand for federal
student loan borrowers I can't point out
enough how many people are devastated
emotionally today devastated over this
decision
but now it's what are we going to do
next your payments are restarting in
October interest starts in September we
got to make a plan we've got to get on a
budget we've got to pay this debt off
and we are here to help you because we
believe you're the hero not the
government